wir schauen auf einen weiteren
kriminalfall heute von der donau ein
plastik sagt der treibt dort im fluss
und in diesem seine leiche eine
kinderleiche heute entdeckt unsere
reporter sind im einsatz auf der suche
nach den hintergründen es ist ein
kanufahrer der unweit der staustufe in
vohburg am vergangenen donnerstag den
grausigen fund macht einen plastiktüten
gewitter gegenstand treibt im wasser mit
dem paddel bugsierte den gegenstand ans
ufer dann ruft er die polizei
zunächst nehmen die beamten das bündel
mit auf die wache erst jetzt stellt sich
heraus in den plastiktüten steckt die
stark verweste leiche eines kindes
[Musik]
ergebnis der gerichtsmedizinischen
untersuchung es handelt sich bei der
leiche um einen vier- bis sechsjährigen
jungen nach bild-informationen muss das
plastik bündel bereits lange zeit im
wasser getrieben sein
mysteriös in der gegend wird kein kind
vermisst mit leichenspürhunden tauchern
sucht die polizei am fundort nach
hinweisen
auf ebenso ein kind vermisst wurde oder
es vermisst gemeldet wurde das ist ein
und jeden fall passen könnte die polizei
will wissen wer hat in der gegend und
vorburg etwas auffälliges beobachtet
noch ist völlig unklar wann wie wo und
warum ist der jugend ins leben gekommen
vor allem der ungeklärte todeszeitpunkt
macht die zeugensuche besonders
schwierig